-♪ Best friends challenge ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
-Here's how the game works.
You draw a question
from the Best Friends Box.
Then the other person guesses
how they think
you would answer that question.
We'll see how many
we can get right.
Ariana, I want you to draw
the first question.
-Okay.
Do I --
-Yeah, you can --
Yes, you ask the question,
-I don't want to -- Okay.
"If I could be any animal,
what animal would I be?"
Oh, so this is you guessing
what I would --
If I could be any animal,
which one would I be?
And I write the real answer.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I write the real answer, too.
But I know you, so...
Any animal,
what animal would you be?
♪♪
Okay, show your answer
to that camera,
and I won't look.
-Okay.
-Okay. Did you show it?
[ Audience "oh"s ]
That sounds like the audience
was surprised there.
Okay.
My answer is...
a kitty cat.
-Oh, that's a good one.
-A seahorse? The hell you --
Hell you talking about?
-I don't know.
-Seahorse?
-I like them.
-You wear, like, bunny ears
and cat ears all the time.
-You're right.
-Like a kitty cat.
-Okay. Alright. You get you get
that one anyway.
-A seahorse? I was close.
-But you can't wear,
like, seahorse ears.
Like, what are those? Like --
-No, but I wouldn't say
you got the drift, but I mean,
you kind of hinted
that you like --
-I know. Sorry, man.
-I don't know.
-I really misled you.
I apologize.
-No, here we go. We're good.
We're good. Ready?
-Okay.
-Phew.
What food do I hate the most?
-Ooh.
Oh, I don't know.
-[ Speaks indistinctly ]
I'm putting
the vibes out there.
♪♪
Barf, just writing it.
I'm going to show my answer.
Don't look.
Oh, you didn't write yet.
You just got it?
-Because I -- go ahead.
-You got my vibe?
Alright. You got my vibe now?
-I think maybe,
-Okay, this is great. Alright.
-Go ahead, you go.
-Don't look. Ready?
Blurf!
[ Laughter ]
Blurf.
-I look -- I tried to look,
but I'm blind, so it doesn't --
I can't see.
-No, it's --
Let's see what your answer was.
-What? Mustard?
Mustard is so delicious.
It's yellow.
It's got, like, spices in it.
It's vinegary. Mayonnaise --
You know why I don't like it.
It reminds me of pus.
-Yeah, I don't like it, either.
[ Audience groaning ]
-Oh, stop.
Yeah, everyone loves it.
This is upsetting.
-I was close, though.
-You were very close.
-In the condiment family.
-You're right.
-We're there.
-Alright, ready? This is
the one we're going to get.
I know it. You pick it.
-Oh, my turn.
-Yeah, here we go.
I'll guess this one.
-Okay.
Man.
-Oh, this is a good one.
Who was my first
celebrity crush?
[ Laughter ]
-A little bit --
a little embarrassing.
You know, yeah.
To have to actually
write it down.
[ Laughing, stammering ]
♪♪
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Both laugh ]
You show it to your --
Oh, maybe I'll show mine first.
-Go ahead.
-Ready?
Don't look.
Ariana, show yours.
[ Laughter ]
-Is that bad?
-[ As Jim Carrey ]
Let me show you something.
[ Normal voice ] First celebrity
crush, Jim Carrey.
Very close. I was very close.
This is the one that counts.
Alright.
What is my most embarrassing
bad habit?
Why did you write it that fast?
Like, that all the other ones,
you really thought about it,
you know, and then this one --
Lookit, you're writing
like three sentences.
Oh, my gosh.
♪♪
Alright, I'm gonna
show mine first.
Should I show mine first?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-My most embarrassing
bad habit is...
I laugh too much.
-No, I like your laugh.
You're good in that department.
This was the one --
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-That's right, 'cause
I'm your second crush!
I got you, girl!
Ariana Grande, everybody!
We've taken
the best friends challenge
and we've proven
that we are best friends.
But you wanted to challenge me
to a game tonight,
and there's someone here
that might know you even better.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright. Here we go.
Jessica!
-Hello.
-Jessica Biel. Alright.
Yeah, Jessica, go over there.
You're gonna be in the middle.
Alright, here we go.
-Thanks for letting me hang out.
Bros being bros.
-Yeah, bros being brow
right here.
-It's pretty exciting.
-Jess, this is for you.
-Oh, thanks.
-We're gonna play a game.
This is for me.
-Okay.
-Justin, here are your cards.
Now, here's how this game
is going to work, okay?
Justin, you're gonna ask us
a question about yourself.
Jessica and I
will write down our answers
and then you'll reveal
the correct answer,
and we'll see which one of us
knows you better.
-Okay.
-There are your questions
right here. We have your
questions written down.
Justin, let's see
the first question.
"Who's my all-time
favorite rapper?"
-Ooh.
-Great question.
-Trick question.
-Oh, trick --
There's two, actually.
-Oh. Okay.
Okay.
-Favorite rappers
is a trick question?
There's two of them?
So it's one rapper that's gone
under different names, maybe?
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Alright?
-[ Laughs ]
-What'd you write down?
Mase and André 3000.
-Mase and André 3000.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I just put Run-D.M.C.
I didn't understand,
but I knew it was three.
There's three, but there's two.
Whoa!
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Of course you know that.
-Of course I know this.
-Alright. Let's get
to the next question,
the ones
that your best buddy knows.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, come on.
I got to get one of these.
Okay. "What's
my go-to cocktail?"
Come on.
-Oh.
Okay.
Tricky.
Some options here.
-It's one of two things.
-Agreed.
♪♪
-Oh, no. You look --
Oh, gosh.
-Feeling confident?
-I'm -- Kind of.
One, two, three. Show.
-Three.
-Tequila mule.
-Gin and --
-What is going on?
What is a tequila mule?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-A tequila mule.
-Gin and tonics.
We drink gin and tonics.
That's what we drink.
You don't like it?
You don't like my --
You don't like
what I do for you?
The beverages we make
and then have,
that's not fun for you?
-I think it is fun.
It's just not the most fun.
-Okay, yeah.
Thank you. What is tequila mule?
What is a mule?
-Tequila mule is --
[ Laughter ]
Tequila is in it.
Ginger beer and lime
and on the rocks.
-Oh, my gosh.
Alright, stop,
let's keep playing the game.
What's the next question?
Go on.
Hey, I'm over here, buddy.
Yeah, here we go.
Come on. I can catch up.
I can catch up. Here we go.
"What is my safe--"
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Your safe word.
-Ready?
What? What?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-[ Speaks indistinctly ]
No, that's not --
No. Dude, how the heck
did that just happen?
[ Laughter ]
That is so bizarre, dude.
That is so bizarre.
-I don't know.
-Things just got weird.
Yeah. No, dude.
[ Laughs ]
What -- How would you -- Why
would we all guess pineapple?
It has nothing --
That is so ridiculous.
That makes me laugh. Okay.
-I don't know what happened.
-Oh, my gosh, dude.
[ Laughs ]
Oh, my gosh.
We have a safe word.
That is hilarious.
[ Laughter ]
Pineapple, pineapple, pineapple.
-Pineapple, pineapple.
-Oh.
-[ Sighs ]
-[ Exhales sharply ]
-[ Laughs ]
I can't believe it.
"What number am I thinking of
between 1 and 5,000?"
-What?
Uh...
♪♪
Oh, I thought
you were giving a hint.
Okay. That's okay.
Alright.
-I want this.
-So do I.
-Show our answers.
What do you got?
2,300. I have 4,297.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How did we guess --
How did we guess that --
How do we guess that one?
-You know what, guys?
-I guess we really are soul
mates.
We're best friends.
-I'm done.
-Really?
-You're done?
-You know what?
Bye.
-Wait, no, stop.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jess, come back!
♪♪
Jess!
Jess, come back!
[ Cheers and applause ]
So here we go.
And this is your marker
and your pad here.
And I'll read
the first question here.
Okay. Demi, if --
if I were a Disney princess,
which one would I be?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Alright. Time's up.
-Okay. [ Laughs ]
-There's no time. Alright.
Demi, you can show it
to that camera.
What did you write?
What princess would I be?
Oh, I didn't know that
Cinderella's your --
-Yeah.
-Yes.
I said Belle
from "Beauty and the Beast."
-[ Laughs ]
-But I put --
-Mama?
-I put maybe Moana just in
case because I didn't know.
I was just hedging my bets.
My girls love Moana now,
so I didn't want
to take their princess.
-Oh, got it.
-But I would be Belle
because that's more my --
-Cute.
-Remember, I'm 43 years old.
Alright.
Alright, good. So, yeah.
-Okay.
-Alright. Here we go.
-Ready?
-Yes.
-Is that question one?
-Yeah, then you're perfect.
Alright.
-If Demi was stranded
on a deserted island,
what one thing
would she bring with her?
-Definitely not spicy pickles.
[ Laughter ]
Oh!
♪♪
Okay. Ready?
-Okay.
-Here's my answer.
Your two dogs,
Batman and the other one.
-[ Laughs ] The other one.
And Cinderella.
-Oh, that's right, Cinderella
and Batman.
What did you say?
-I said my iPhone.
-Oh, my God. Come on!
-I'm a terrible owner.
-You told me about your dogs.
You love your dogs.
-I know, but if you had
your iPhone,
you might get service
and you might could
call your way off the island.
-I don't even get service
in New York City.
I mean, come on.
Deserted island. Alright.
I'll read the next question.
Here we go. Ready?
Okay.
-I should've said my dogs.
-If we were going to binge watch
a TV show together,
what show would we pick?
I know one. Here we go.
♪♪
-This is not gonna be right.
-This is going to be right.
My BFF, what did you say?
-[ Laughs ]
-"Walking Dead"?
-I know.
-That's similar.
-It's my favorite show.
-I said "Riverdale,"
which is...
[ Laughs ]
That's too scary for me.
-Really?
-I can't do that.
"Riverdale," Archie,
this is scary enough for me.
There's murder.
[ Laughter ]
Jughead's involved.
It's a great show.
"Riverdale" on the CW.
Alright.
-Okay. Ready?
-Yeah.
If we became one person and had
to combine our names,
what would our new name be?
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
-Do we do it at similar times?
I think we've got
to get this one, BFF.
Alright.
They have to combine our names,
what is your answer?
-Jemetria.
[ Laughter ]
-Similar.
Jemmi!
There you go.
Demi Lovato, everybody!
So why don't you draw
the first question?
Here you go. So this would be me
and that's you.
-Okay.
-Alright. So, yeah,
you draw the first question.
I'm not looking.
-Don't look.
-No, but I guess
I'll hear it anyway.
-What is my favorite sandwich?
-Your favorite sandwich?
Mark Ruffalo's
favorite sandwich.
Oh, you're moving like that's
like a peanut butter-y jam,
but that's too obvious.
Or is it not?
Alright.
Alright. Now you show
your answer to that camera.
I'm not gonna look.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Here's my answer.
I think your
favorite sandwich is
the BLT.
[ Audience groans ]
Oh, it didn't happen.
Wait, what do you mean?
That is --
-So close.
-It really is close?
Bacon, lettuce, tomato.
-And peanut butter and jelly.
-No!
[ Laughter ]
-You got it right
with your first.
You went with the --
You gotta go with the first.
-I know, I thought PB&J.
-The first thing! The first one!
You want peanut butter
and jelly.
-I know, you were doing it.
I honestly -- Yeah.
-You don't even know me. I feel
like you don't even know me.
-Come on.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
-We've been through so much
together.
-Here we go. No, it's okay.
Come on.
Here we go. Ready for this?
Uh --
Oh.
-Ah, come on.
-What do you think is
my best physical asset?
[ Laughter ]
-On national television?
-I am, like -- I am having
a hard time answering.
-Me too. This is really hard.
I'm having a hard time with it
because it's so hard for you
to know what your best asset is.
There's so many.
-Yeah.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
That's how best friends
treat each other.
[ Laughter ]
When...
♪♪
-Alright.
-Alright, ready?
-Yeah.
I have my answer.
I'm gonna show camera first.
Don't look.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, go.
That's not it.
-Alright, alright.
-No, that -- [ Laughs ]
Yeah. Sorry about that.
-What was it?
-I just put there's too many.
I thought you were
giving me another hint.
[ Laughter ]
-That's why I listed two.
-There's "two" many.
-More than -- More than one.
-"Two" many. We're men.
-And we're men.
-"Man" in "many."
We're too many people.
-This thing's --
-Manly people.
-It's just --
-We're gonna get this one here.
-It's just "two" "man"y.
-We're gonna get this one.
We're gonna get this one.
-Alright.
-This is good.
-Doesn't mean anything.
Doesn't mean --
Here, you draw.
You pick from this thing.
We'll get this one.
Don't worry about it.
-I feel like I'm giving
a Christmas gift to my wife,
-And? Does she enjoy it?
-It's just so hard
to get it right.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on. No, no.
-So much pressure.
Alright, number two, this is me.
-Yep, here we go.
-Oh, oh.
-Why -- I can look.
-What is my biggest fear?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
-I think I got this one.
-You better get this one.
-Okay. You show yours.
[ Laughter ]
This is --
This one's a shoo-in for you.
-Your biggest fear, I think,
is...
-Drowning in mil--
-...to be alone in this world.
[ Laughter ]
-To be alone
in this world
in a pool of milk.
-With a weight
attached to my foot.
-But you think a pool of milk,
and then you have a PB&J,
and, oh, drowning in milk,
it makes sense. Alright,
we still have a chance.
We have one more. Right?
We have one more.
And then the speed round,
so here you go.
This is -- Ready?
Who is my favorite superhero?
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
Come on.
Come on, come on, come on.
Come on, man.
You know what's up.
You know what is up.
Okay, y'all?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-My friend!
Best friends forever!
Mark Ruffalo, everybody!